1933 goes in heavily for streamlining
here's a car in the low price field
whose body design looks well into the
future the shimmering gold tissue even
in the 1930s the new york international
auto show was all about looking ahead in
time that has continued through the
decades and as the show opens this
weekend for the first time since the
pandemic the future is looking electric
michael george is at the jacob javits
center here in manhattan with more
michael good morning
dana good morning here's something you
don't see every day an indoor test track
where you can test ride some of the
latest electric vehicles like this one
here now it's been three years since the
last car show but finally the crowds and
the cars are back
car lovers are racing back to the javits
center for the new york international
auto show and it's a long time coming i
know last year they were supposed to
have one but it got canceled last minute
so
you know it's nice to be back out
somewhat seems normal now for the past
two years this show had to be canceled
due to covid the javits center was
converted into a makeshift hospital then
a mass vaccination clinic but this year
it's back and the mood here is electric
the big trend of the show this year is
definitely electrification tim stevens
is editor in chief of cnet's road show
he says all the major manufacturers are
showing off their new electric vehicles
everything from the 27 thousand dollar
nissan leaf to the 90 thousand dollar
ford lightning platinum and the porsche
tai can turbo s with a
and eighty five thousand dollar price
tag people have only had the choice for
teslas for so long people are just
excited to have a lot of choices on the
market now evs beat gas powered vehicles
for awards in nearly every major
category including car of the year the
hyundai ioniq 5
we took a spin in the big winner
hyundai's ioniq 5. how's the
acceleration on this it's pretty good
i'll give it a little gas here
the 0-60 is rated at like 5.2 seconds
the ionix starts at just under 44
thousand dollars comes with a high-tech
dash and travels 300 miles on a charge
it looks like nothing else in the road
right now but on top of looking great it
drives really nicely too also on display
here new york city's new fleet of evs
including a street sweeper soon to hit
the city streets or how about a tesla
taxi able to drive two full days on a
single charge
the auto industry charging forward to an
ev future
and doors open here at the javits center
at 10 am the show is open through april
24th jeff
i think michael's standing on the test
track there so
watch it watch out
careful
um they're going very good they're going
slow
okay
not slow enough but very cool that you
can test the cars out in because it's
electric
the future is now how about that